hey crazies we all know the difference
between space and time right you measure
space with rulers and you measure time
with clocks then Einstein comes along
with his crazy hair and says they're
just two parts of the same thing
space-time who does he think he is a
scientist
how dare he just prove our feelings with
facts oh wait okay so so let's assume
he's right about this what the heck is
time then this episode was made possible
by generous supporters on patreon a
major goal of physics is to make
accurate predictions about the behavior
of matter and light and for centuries
that was done through three dimensional
dynamics the study of forces and their
effects on motion Newton's laws were of
pinnacle importance objects might sit
still but they could also move from one
place to another over time whether or
not the forces were balanced determined
exactly what the objects would do forces
determined acceleration acceleration
determined velocity and velocity
determined the path taken it was very
methodical a leads to B which leads to C
dynamics is all about keeping track of
vectors to predict paths the simplest
example is a straight path with steady
motion that means there are no forces on
the object or if there are forces
they're perfectly balanced if the object
speeds up there's an unbalanced force in
the direction of motion if it slows down
the unbalanced force is against the
motion if it changes direction the
unbalanced force is toward the new
direction that's the jist of dynamics
and it served as well for centuries then
Einstein came along and changed
everything
well not just Einstein but also makovski
then Hilbert and Grossman and levy
savita all built on the ideas of Gauss
Riemann and Christoffel nobody lives in
a vacuum what was i right
I'm Stein Einstein came along and showed
how space and time are just two parts of
the same thing space-time but if that's
true we can measure time with a ruler or
space with a clock which is actually not
as weird as it sounds
hey map clone how far away is that place
again about ten minutes thanks man
so it's pretty common to give distance
measurements and time units right okay
maybe that's just a Midwestern thing the
point is we actually go the other way
with Einstein's model we measure time as
a distance multiplied by the speed of
light and fam distance units of course
time isn't actually distance there there
are some differences which we'll get to
later but this new model gives us
insights we wouldn't normally see let's
say we've got a clone on a spring his
position is changing in time why are you
using a clone I thought it would look
funny and it did kitchen.you something
else ok fine I'll use a squirrel this
animation is exactly what we'd expect
out of dynamics but Einstein and friends
imagine time is just another dimension
so instead of this we have something
that looks more like this as the
squirrel bounces back and forth he also
moves up through time we call it a
spacetime diagram because it has both
the space axis and a time axis points on
this diagram are called events and this
path represents all the events in the
squirrels past and future history
it's everything that has happened in
everything that ever will happen to the
squirrel well at least what we predict
has happened and predict will happen
this is just a mathematical prediction
no one actually expects him to do this
forever treating time is if it's just
another dimension turns
three-dimensional dynamics into
four-dimensional static geometry yes
static geometry I'm only showing motion
in this animation so it feels more
familiar to you but this is more like an
omnipresent and on the temporal
viewpoint in this model nothing moves
all these events just exist it's a
static image again it's not necessarily
reality I'm not saying the past and the
future are already written this is just
a model a powerful model but a model
nonetheless so let's see what some of
those dynamics examples
earlier look like now if a squirrel is
sitting still on a table this is its
path through space-time it's completely
up and down it's only through time
a squirrel moving steadily to the right
has a spacetime path like this
a squirrel moving steadily to the left
has the opposite path accelerated paths
look a little different if the squirrel
is speeding up as it moves across the
table its space-time path is curved a
similar thing happens if the squirrel
slows down its path is also curved
straight paths are steady motion curved
paths are accelerated motion a spacetime
diagram makes telling them apart
extremely obvious you don't have to
consider the dynamics you can just see
it in the geometry so far this is all
pretty general stuff to do anything more
specific we need some math say we've got
two events maybe up high five in
Michigan and a rocket launch in Florida
each of them happens at a particular
place and a particular time
maybe they happen 1,200 miles apart and
one day apart but how long is this
separation line directly between them to
figure that out
we're gonna need Pythagorean theorem yep
the thing you probably had memorized in
elementary school
a squared plus B squared equals C
squared where a B and C are the side
lengths of a triangle in space
it tells us the straight-line distance
between objects or locations given some
set of coordinates why is that an S you
know I don't actually know okay Google
why is s used for position it's short
for the German word stricka--
which means roots huh who knew okay so S
is for route
apparently Delta means change in so this
is the change in position otherwise
known as displacement we also have a
triangle in our space-time diagram but
we have a slight problem I've been
saying the entire video that space and
time aren't exactly the same thing
this squirrel can move in either
direction in space along the table but
it must always move forward in time the
forward more time
we're just pretending like in space you
might say we're imagining it the time
axis is more like an imaginary axis than
a real one so let's stop dancing around
it and just say it's imaginary
that means Pythagorean theorem for this
triangle looks like this we've picked up
a negative sign space-time is non
Euclidean that means these diagrams
aren't going to obey your intuitions
about geometry these axes are
perpendicular but so are these seriously
these are perpendicular this this and
this are right triangles all of them are
right triangles any paths along the 45
degree diagonals have a length of zero
this picture and this picture are the
same picture just from two different
perspectives parallelism and causality
might be preserved but angles and
distances are not the geometry is
super-weird to emphasize this difference
instead of calling it a four-dimensional
space-time we call it a 3d plus 1 D
space-time or just a three plus one
space-time with this model wall
extremely weird makes predictions that
match reality this equation keeps the
speed of light constant it's just the
maximum speed of causality it's the
maximum speed of cause and effect with
some quick trigonometry it predicts the
time and length depend on the observer
well as long as you remember to use
hyperbolic trig functions instead of the
regular ones it predicts a lot of weird
things but we've verified them all by
experiment they're all real things that
happen and things get even weirder when
space-time is curved let's consider a
path like this hey didn't you agree not
to use clothes change my mind I do what
I want there are actually two possible
reasons it would be curved the first
possibility is that there's a force on
the clothes we mentioned that one
earlier the other possibility is that
space-time itself is curved yes this is
a real possibility to describe a curved
path with Pythagorean theorem we need to
be a little more careful this only works
on straight paths between events so
let's imagine this curved path is just a
collection of events if the events are
close enough together then the mini path
between each pair of events is
approximately straight
buckle-up crazies it's calculus time
each of those little straight pieces is
called a line element and since they're
straight we can use Pythagorean theorem
on them it's just like the one with the
deltas except we use a lowercase D
instead it lets us know it's a tiny
change rather than a big change this
notation is really important so you
better get used to the D wait that came
out wrong you know what I mean a line
element tells us how nearby events in
space-time are separated from each other
this is for what we'd call flat
space-time meaning there's no curvature
but the space-time around a non rotating
spherical object will look different
it's curved the line element must be
adjusted because different events have
different separations even the time
component has to be adjusted time can be
curved this path might be curved not
because of a force but because time
itself is curved which is kind of crazy
but the concept of curved space-time has
made accurate predictions about our
universe deviations in the orbit of
mercury gravitational lensing
gravitational waves the existence of
black holes even the appearance of black
holes
time isn't universal anymore it depends
on an observers motion and their
proximity to high concentrations of
matter and light time is relative and it
can be curved but you know what isn't
relative causality
if one event can influence another then
the order of those events is always
maintained even in all this relativistic
weirdness so what exactly is time time
is a representation of causality
including a time axis in our diagram
turns a dynamics problem into a geometry
problem straight paths are steady motion
curved paths are accelerated space-time
diagrams are powerful tools but they're
just tools when it comes down to it time
is about causality we may not agree on
the space between two events
or the time between two events but if
they're causally connected everyone
agrees on the order of those events
without causality we might not even
agree on past present and future
causality is where our concept of time
comes from causality is more fundamental
than time
so did I set off your Google assistant
today please share in the comments
thanks for liking and sharing this video
don't forget to subscribe if you'd like
to keep up with us and until next time
remember it's okay to be a little crazy
I don't believe 2d creatures could see
each other that way I'm not sure we can
imagine one or two dimensional spaces
can they really see that 2d surface is a
3d sphere doesn't light need three
dimensions to exist it's just a metaphor
for us okay I do appreciate you keeping
me on my toes though anyway thanks for
watching